vous prêtez attention à la position de
vos pieds de veau gens ce lundi matin à
montigny le bretonneux la séance de
massage bébé démarre par une étape
primordiale la relaxation des mamans
pendant plus d'une heure elles vont
ensuite stimuler tous les sens du bébé à
l'aide de gestes précis les bénéfices
sont nombreux au niveau du ventre le
massage a des vertus anti coliques et
s'ils ne font pas forcément leur nuit
les bébés auront au moins un sommeil de
meilleure qualité
est ce que tu veux bien que tu m as les
gens lola avant de démarrer le massage
les mamans demande toujours
l'autorisation à leurs enfants
les séances peuvent démarrer dans les
semaines qui suivent la naissance
jusqu'à l'âge de 1 an sauf pour les
enfants porteurs de handicaps où il n'ya
pas de limite d'âge
pendant le massage en apprendre aux
parents à observer leur bébé et du coup
à regarder à repérer les moments où il
est disponible pour le massage ou pas et
on voit la communication entre les
parents qui s'affine et qui vient de
plus en plus fluide et du coup ça ça va
renforcer le lien d'attachement entre
les bébés et leurs parents pour les
mamans c'est aussi un temps privilégié
durant lequel elles prennent du temps
pour se poser souvent elles sont bien
prises en charge pendant pendant toute
leur grossesse à la maternité
et puis quand elle rentre à la maison
avec leur bébé
bah c'est là qu'elle se retrouve tout
seul alors qu'elles ont plein de
questions plein d'interrogations et du
coup pendant les massages basse et elle
retrouve un petit peu cette cette
convivialité sait-on des changes de
partage qui leur fait vraiment du bien
ça me rassure parce que moi c'est mon
premier bébé est en fait j'avais un peu
peur de comment le prendre
est ce que je touchais trop brusquement
ou pas assez avec les massages mais
c'est une approche du toucher et là
aussi moi je peux observer beaucoup les
mamans autour voir comment elle faisait
et ben c'est rassurant de voir comment
les autres font voilà c'est un temps
faut pas son ensemble et voilà on
échange
donc c'est effectivement par le massage
par le corps par le regard
maryline kir et propose des sessions de
cinq séances pour une centaine d'euros
chacune est consacrée à l'apprentissage
de mouvement sur une partie du corps de
quoi pouvoir par la suite elles
réalisées régulièrement chez soi à
domicile